[موسيقى]
هبتدي بكود كده صغيره انه
الوجع الجسدي دايما له دواء او ليه ممكن
اي بين ناخذ له دواء هيبقى كويس بس العلاج
الوجع الايموشنل او في السيكولات دي كله
عمره ما بنلاقي له علاج الاطفال في
المستشفيات الاطفال في المستشفيات دايما
خايفه وقلقانه وما عندهاش اي حاجه تطمنها
فانا قررت اخد سبت وورد ده واكون مع
الاطفال في بتاعهم
بتاعتها في المستشفيات بس انا كنت
بتاعتي الجوني دايما مش وان بلس 2 ممكن
تبقى حاجه ما حدش متخيلها خالص وتبقى هي
دي الروت اللي انت بتاخديها
لغايه ما توصلي
الفراش هولد ممكن ما كانتش اصلا
فالستب ممكن ترجعك لورا وممكن تطلعك لقدام
وممكن توقفك مكانك مش معنى انه يبقى فيه
سكساس بالعكس ممكن ساعات بتبقى فيلير بس
انا قررت اعمل كده زي ما قلت عشان حاجه
مهمه قوي ان احنا نبقى باصين على حاجه بقى
لها سنين عمرها ما بتتغير لبس التمريض
بتاع المستشفيات الحاجات دي كلها وما حدش
فكر عمره انه ده بياثر بشكل قوي قوي على
على الي عايشين جوه المستشفى فانا قررت
اخذ الستاب ده
يعني ايه ديزا يعني ابقى مسؤوله بيحس بايه
من اول ما بيدخل من باب المستشفى لحد ما
بيطلع بيشوف ايه بيلمس ايه بانكونتر ايه
عشان اقدر اديزاين بقى بروبليم
فاول كولابريشن ممكن يكون غير حياتي عشان
ما كانش قريتي ان انا
اكونتر حاجه زي كده هو ان الديزاين
في 57
وايدزاين لبس التمريض
لبس
القاعده مع الاطفال غريبه
ممكن ما لهاش اند يعني كنت فاكره ان انا
هروح اقعد معاهم شهر شهرين عشان نطلع
الديزاين عشان نعرف نطلع حاجه
انت بتتعاملي مع حد سنتي قوي عايزه
انسباير وعايزه تقولي له ان احنا معك بس
بطريقه ان دايركت حتى لو انت مش موجوده
لانه انا كمان ان انا اقف واقول انه دي
كومبليتلي نينت عليا انا عمري ما اتعرضت
لحاجه زي كده اكسبيرينس جديده بتحسسني قد
ايه احنا بلاستيك مش بس من ناحيه الماديه
للاديوكيشن
بتاعنا ومن التاب دي هي اللي خلتني اطلع
قدام واقول لا احنا
ولينا حاجه نقدر نعملها كل حد في السكوب
بتاعه ممكن يعمل حاجه بجد مفيده
[موسيقى]
كتبنا للولاد بكره احلى تحدي اي صعب احنا
معك بنحبك
اضحك كل يوم جديد وابتدى يبقى هو ده جزء
من البراندينج بتاع المستشفى المستشفى
دايما بتطلعه في الاعلانات لانه
المسج بتاعتهم امبدت كان عمر ما حد فكر
يغيره
من هنا بقى اكتشفت انه ايه ده
يعني كنت فاكره ان هو ما كنتش عارفه بتاعه
لغايه ما التمريض لبسه لغايه ما الفين
ممرضه لبسه لبسه في المستشفى وانا ببص
اللي هو هو ايه ده هو احنا ازاي لبس
التمريض كان ساده فبتبتدي تغيري حاجه ذانت
ما حدش كان فكر يغيرها قبل كده فمن اليوم
ده جات لي ام قالت لي انت نور قلت لها اه
فرقت لي شكرا ان خليتيني اضحك في يوم ما
كنتش ناويه اضحك فيه فعرفت ساعتها انه
هو ده اللي انا يمكن جيت عشان اساعد الناس
في
فيسكوب صعب قوي
من يوميها قررت ان انا هعمل شركه والشركه
دي بتساعد بيشنس ب 90% من شغلها بتساعد
فيجنس في المستشفيات بتاعه
بتسهل على الناس الصعبه قوي الاكسبيرينس
سهل
بعدين بقى
بهيه ويكنج بانك تشتغلي مع ستات عندهم
كانسر دي الست الكبيره سهله قوي قوي انك
تجرحي فهو خط رفيع قوي من ست او تجرحيها
قوي
فالتعامل معهم كان صعب قوي لانه كنت فاكره
انه ما فيش حاجه اصعب
انكدز بس اكتشفت لا انه بهيه الستات عندهم
يعني ان هم عندهم كانسر دي اصغر مشكله في
حياتهم مش اجمر واحده
فالج نفسها كانت يعني اوبرينج اب بقى
انه هو ازاي الستات دي قويه قوي مش بتتكلم
ازاي الستات دي الجوني بتاعتهم عامله كده
وهم بكامل الاكسبتنس والسعاده والفرحه
وهما مبسوطين يعني لما عملت الستائر او
لما عملت اللبس التمريض كان كل حد بيقعد
يقول لي ايه الهبل ده
التمريض لابس كلام
لا لا ده ما لهوش لازمه احنا ندي فلوس في
التبرعات احسن بس لا الستات واصله لهم ده
لانه دي حاجه معموله لهم ده سبيكس
وهما بجد اتبسط قوي من الفكره وخلاص
والستات بيحبوها التمريض مش بيحبني شويه
بس عادي ممكن دي حاجه ممكن نتقبلها يعني
[موسيقى]
كان مستشفى مجدي يعقوب مستشفى مجدي يعقوب
اه بنتعامل مع اطفال ممكن تكون
لسبعه وخمسين بس لما تيجي بقى نحط البوينز
لا هي مش شبه مستشفى 57 خالص هو اه اطفال
وكل حاجه بس توكينج لكيدز عندهم كانسر غير
توكين لكيدز عندهم القلب لانه ده بيقعد في
المستشفى وقت مختلف
الكانسي كيدز بتقعد في المستشفى تقريبا 3
شهور الاطفال اللي عندها
بتقعد بالكثير قوي اسبوعين فلما تيجي
تكلمي الطفلين لازم تتكلمي مختلف قوي لان
عشان تعرفي فعلا تحلي مشكله فرو ديزاين
كينج وده اللي احنا بنعمله ان احنا دايما
بنحاول نشوف ايه في المشكله مع الاطفال دي
او ازاي نقدر نساعدهم عشان نقدر نبات ده
في الديزاين
من هنا قررت انه اسالهم انتم الدكاتره
مشكلتكم ايه مع الاطفال في المستشفى فكان
بس ردهم ان هم مش بيمشوا على العادات
الصحيه اللي المفروض يمشوا عليها زي ان هم
ياكلوا اكل هلسي ان هم يلعبوا رياضه ان هم
يروحوا المدرسه ويجوا يتابعوا في المستشفى
فقررنا ان احنا نعمل حاجه لذيذه قوي ان
احنا ننزل بمستوى فكرينا سوا فكر الاطفال
مش العكس الطفل عنده ثلاث سنين عمره ما
هيفهم ليه لازم ياكلها اكل هلسي ليه ما
ينفعش ياكل شيبسي وليه لازم يعمل رياضه بس
بهداوه ما ينفعش يعملها ما ينفعش يجري بعد
العمليه فلازم احنا بالعكس اللي ننزل
الميه سات بتاعتنا لهم عشان نقدر نساعدهم
بجد
دول كانوا السكس
بتاعنا وكل واحده فيهم بتقول للاطفال حاجه
كل واحده بتساعدهم في المستشفى على حاجه
فعندنا هادي الرياضي
بيلعب رياضه بس بهداوه عندنا فكهاني فيه
جو عندنا دكتوره سوسو اللي بتتابع معه كل
اسبوع لما بيجري عنده عبود المحبوب انه
لازم يبقى قلبه دايما طيب همم
وخير يعني وعندنا فؤاد الفرفوش دايما
بيبقى بيضحك
يعني وعندنا فنانه نونو ده اوبيسلي انا بس
يعني كنت بحاول اقول لهم ان هم لازم
يرسموا اكسبريس على الورق وكده فده كان
اللبس اللي هم بيدخلوا بيه العمليات وده
كان اول مره بنغير حاجه استعجنن زي كده
بدل ما بيلبسوا الازرق
الجاون ده اولادي هي اكسبيرينس مخيفه قوي
على الاطفال ان هم لابسين كده ومش عارفين
هم رايحين فين ولا بيعملوا ايه ولا البنج
ده بيوديهم فين فان احنا نحاول نغير
اكسبيرينس ثقيله على الاطفال كده ان احنا
ندخلهم لابسين كده وارادي
يبقوا متقبلين ان هم داخلين بس
وهيطلعوا تاني وهيبقوا زي الفل وهيبقوا
كويسين
فده كان اول حاجه غيرناها وبعدين ده ثاني
حاجه غيرنا
ده كانت للاطفال بيستنوا فيها دي كانت
في مجدي يعقوب الاعداد كبيره قوي قوي قوي
فقرروا يعملوا عشان يعرفوا كل العادات دي
فدي كانت
بيقعدوا فيها
الاطفال دي كانت حاجه بالنسبه لي مرعبه
يعني دي بالليل كانت اوضه رعب فقررنا ان
احنا
ونغير من ده
بالظبط تسع ايام جيرني قصيره شويه بس
سمبل اكتس عرفنا نغير والنيف في المكان
ممكن ما يكونش يكلف كثير ممكن يكون ما
اخذش وقت كتير بس فرق جدا جدا مع الاطفال
الاطفال في الاول بتقعد على حجر اهاليها
وهي مستنيه دلوقتي بتقعد بتقعد تلعب في
مكان
يعني
بيقلل اكليس مش ده بس اللي احنا عملناه في
مجدي او بس مجدي اقوم
لانه عرفنا فيها 5 اكسبيرينس
مهمه لانه الاطفال بتبتدي تشم تعرف هي
بتشم ايه وبتحس بايه
طبقناها على لانه دلوقتي بقى في حاجات
بيعملها بايده وكمان
يعني سنتين
انه الاطفال بتشم
[موسيقى]
وفانيليا في في
اوض ليه عشان بايستاتيكس سانتين بيقلل
الطفل بيحسها جوه المستشفى
ده كان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كل كل ستات من دول او كل برودكت من دول
كانوا
وحدهم كل واحده بتعلمني حاجه كل حاجه كل
مره
حاجه مختلفه اه ايكون
بس اكتشفت انه لا واي نوت كلها جت من فكره
ممكن يكون ناس كتير قوي شافوها مختلفه لا
ما تشتغلي حاجه عاديه ما تروحي تعملي حاجه
عاديه زي الناس ليه حاجات متعبه لك بس لا
انا قررت انه انا عايزه اعمل حاجه مختلفه
لان انا جيت الدنيا عشان اعمل حاجه مختلفه
مش عشان نفضل كلنا بنعمل نفس الحاجه وجبت
الدنيا عشان انا عايزه اساعد الناس
وان احنا ندي للناس اديسنت اكسبيرينس
ونطمنهم بحاجه بسيطه قوي لو انا كنت يعني
لو انا كنت في الاول خالص وانا في الجامعه
قلت لا انا انا هخلص وهعمل كليه وهشتغل
كده ما كنتش وصلت لكل ده فعايزين
انه تاخذي تاخذي التاب دي وما نبقاش
خايفين منها لانه اللي هيحصل يعني لو
اخدنا وفشلت ايه اللي هيحصل ولا حاجه
هترجعي وراه وتبتدي تاني من الاول عشان
نقدر نعمل حاجه جديده
في ناس كثير قوي بيبقى عندها ايدي بس
بتبقى خايفه من الرياكشن او خايفه ان الاي
دي ما تنجحش
يعني
انه دائما
يعني ان احنا نعمل حاجات جديده عشان بجد
نساعد الناس وعشان نعمل نبقى
اوثانتك ونبقى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]